nothing is quite what it seems in
Cameroon this is the separatist area
Amba Sonia they call it the government
soldiers are on red alert they face
constant attacks from the separatists
here and half a million civilians have
upped and fled their homes
we've gained rare access to the camera
in military the soldiers are regularly
accused of brutality they're trying to
quash an often savage armed insurgency
they want independence for the minority
english-speaking Anglophone areas
severing ties with the majority
french-speaking government the
Fighting's led to terrible destruction
and all too often the soldiers are seen
as the enemy how do we know the army did
not do this
for me the reason
because they don't like the Anglophone
people the secessionist that's what
they're saying I'm speaking English I'm
funny if you are here today is for the
welfare for the well-being of your
family isn't it then why will you
destroy what you have earned with so
difficult you are wasting your life but
in this footage soldiers are clearly
seen setting homes alight they've been
accused of torturing and executing
villagers to crush the separatist
movement claims the military and says
they're all staged for use on social
media I'm telling you again we might not
be Saints but we do our best
understand that defendant incorrigible
wanted to develop themselves the
soldiers take us to a hospital which was
set on fire huge sections have been
destroyed cinders at least four patients
died in their beds as the flames swept
through the wards with the soldiers all
around us the director says she's been
told the separatists started it but
footage at the time shows soldiers
standing by watching as the fire raged
leading to suspicions over exactly who
was responsible
[Music]
the military presents us with hours of
material which they say documents
atrocities by the separatists most is
too gruesome to broadcast we're shown
decapitated soldiers their genitals cut
limbs amputated most of this has been
uploaded on websites run by separatists
in this video the man's accused of
spying for the military his beating and
torture and he's been execution again
uploaded on social media and stoking
more fear whilst we're in the area a
truck loaded with aid for displaced
civilians is set alight by the
separatists the food destroyed there are
terrible human rights abuses on both
sides in this conflict fingers and limbs
are cut off as punishment for ignoring
the separatist boycott of government
businesses you're not going to work yes
I'm a security separatist fighters
who've apparently handed themselves in
echoed the military's view perhaps
unsurprisingly given the close army
observation well fighting because I was
in the dice for us the give us bad
notions that we should take out against
States so that we can we can't separate
the two aspera fund the insurgency and
the leader told us they're dealing with
a brutal authoritarian regime the regime
is desperate at this particular moment
it's using every means to smell the the
Amazonian war independence and to escape
you know crimes against humanity but the
savagery in Cameroon has been largely
ignored by the wider world and the
claims and counterclaims of brutality
just keep on coming Alex Crawford Sky
News in Cameroon